okay so uncharted is now out in the uk
and the movie brings nathan drake to the
big screen i'm aware that the film isn't
out in the us yet so if you want to
learn our spoiler-free thoughts on it
then timecodes will be linked below the
end of the video should give you our
general feelings without going into too
much detail but from here on out it's
full spoilers ahead if you enjoy the
breakdown then please hit the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this every day
without the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
there
enjoyed
places out there you can't find on any
map
they're not gone
they're just lost okay so though
uncharted isn't a direct adaptation of
the games it does cherry-pick certain
parts of them this includes nathan's
origin and like we learned in the fourth
game nate grew up with his brother sam
in an orphanage over seen by nuns told
that they were direct descendants of sir
francis drake the pair became fascinated
with history after a running with the
police sam ended up being a naughty dog
and he ran away from the orphanage never
to be seen again however he left a ring
behind for his brother which belonged to
drake that i'm sure you'll recognize
from the game series this plays heavily
into the post-credits scene which we'll
talk about later on in the video and it
definitely seems like they're setting up
a sequel now nate spent 15 years on his
own in new york making a living through
bartending whilst also pickpocketing on
the side you've got to pick a pocket
door too one fateful night he meets
victor sullivan an old friend of sam's
who'd worked with him and tried to track
down the magellan fortune this is the
largest amount of undiscovered gold in
the world and the key to finding it lies
in two crucifix keys so the initiatives
drake that they can help find his
brother but it's revealed in the film
that victor thinks he's dead and he's
just really using nate for his own ends
sam used to write postcards to nathan
all of the time and sully believes that
there's a secret he told him which will
uncover the fortune much like the
original game nate kind of goes back and
forth over whether he should trust
sulyanat and at several points the side
characters say he must ask what really
happened with sam now the pair set off
to uncover the mystery of where the
treasure is buried and there are several
key scenes that riff directly on the
source material the crucifix is held at
an auction and this somewhat pulls from
the level in the fourth game titled once
a thief much like the original title
nade is tasked with cutting the power
and it's here that he meets the two main
antagonists of the movie the first is
monkorda a wealthy treasure hunter who's
angered by his father's insistence that
they give away their fortune because of
the blood that was shed when making it
obsessed with uncovering the miguel and
gold he hires two people to track this
down the first of these being joe
braddock now she's a completely original
character for the franchise but she's
heavily based on nadine who also
appeared in the 4th entry braddock is a
cold-blooded mercenary that's completely
ruthless and not only has she got up
close and personal with sully it's also
believed that she killed sam now the
other person that moncada hired is chloe
frazier a femme fatale from the games
who was first introduced in uncharted 2.
chloe is completely distrustful of
everyone and this is because when she
was growing up she found a platinum
trophy that a dad took and ran off with
just for the clout hey those playstation
games were hard now initially she joins
nate and sully and barcelona but after
they uncover a map to the whereabouts of
the gold she ends up stealing it and
goes back to monkorda as they ascend
into the sky braddock reveals her true
plans and she ends up killing moncada
and taking over his operation just
before she can put an end to chloe it
all goes to hell and we get the awesome
plane scene from the third game i was
lucky enough to watch the film in imax
and this entire park completely blew me
away it really felt like they'd
perfectly captured the games and there's
several iconic things from it such as
the cargo crates that nate has to climb
up during this time sully parachutes
away and chloe ends up driving
moncotta's car off the plane in order to
escape now in the original game nate
ended up catching up to one of these
crates and he used the parachute on it
to slow down his fall here though he
goes to the car gets chloe and then the
pair drop together before they swim to a
resort on one of the neighboring islands
you might recognize one of the guests
here as being nolan north who voiced
nathan in the game series even makes a
joke about how he fell out of a plane
once too and it's one of my favorite
cameos in a thing well ever now pouring
over the maps nate realizes that his
brother wrote messages to him in the
postcards in invisible link using sam
slider he manages to uncover them and
this item actually popped about several
points during the fourth game sam was
somewhat retroactively added into the
law but i do appreciate that they just
hit the ground running with him here and
showed him at the earliest possible
opportunity i never really liked how he
was kind of crowbar into the franchise
and when you think about it chloe was
too she appeared in the second game with
us being told that she and drake had
history but like with sam we see
everything play out in chronological
order this is very much the same with
elena who's completely missing from this
movie and we know from the game timeline
that nate doesn't meet her until long
after he's met chloe now the postcards
point nate to where the treasure is
buried and he somewhat leaves a test for
chloe to see whether she'll work with
him or ditch him at the first available
opportunity she fails and thus strike
heads off on his own these moments on
the speedboat feel like they're ripped
directly from a thief's end and the
climax of the movie takes place at a
similar location to how that entry
wrapped up the fortune is held within
two ships hidden within a cavern and a
lot of the iconography of the approach
to them is taken completely from the
fourth game sully reveals he's been
tracking nate the entire time and after
nadine and a gang arrive there it all
goes down using helicopters they pull
the ships into the air and it somewhat
also plays upon the finale of the first
game in which nate ended up flying
through the sky whilst hanging off some
treasure sadly what's missing from the
movie are the more supernatural elements
that tended to come as the game's true
to a close i remember i did not see the
big zombie twist at the end of the first
one and i know that the fan community is
kind of divided on whether the monsters
that tended to appear at the end of the
games are good or they're just crap i
was always fine on them but naughty dog
did try and drift away from doing more
supernatural things because the games
weren't really designed for creatures
that just run at you whether they will
appear in the sequel we don't know but
after a chase through the sky nate ends
up getting the upper hand and he uses a
cannon and sam slider to bring down
braddock's forces leaving just her nate
hanging off the ship sully has to decide
whether the gold means more to him than
nate and he ends up choosing the ladder
he drops a full bag of it onto braddock
who falls into the ocean and then the
ship drops onto her head can you believe
it should have given her a stern talking
to eight now sully grabbing nate's hand
is somewhat married in the opening of
the movie when sam did the same thing
during his introduction nade also offers
sully the last of his gum which he
wastes and this mirrors an interaction
that nate had with his brother when they
were kids now though nate managed to
salvage some of the gold it won't be
enough to count for the billions that
sully was expecting but the real
unshorted was the friends we made along
the way they'd suggest diving for it and
in the fourth game we opened with him
doing this though there was a bit of a
funny reveal when it turned out that he
wasn't hunting for treasure they fly off
into the sunset with chloe missing out
and it takes us into our first
post-credits scene which drops
immediately after the title in an
undisclosed jail cell we find that sam
is actually still alive he writes a
postcard to his brother saying that he
has to watch his back and this somewhat
ties into the scene that follows it sam
is played by rudy panko and i believe
that the second film will have him
reuniting with his brother in the fourth
game we actually had a prison escape
level involving drake and his brother
which could end up popping up in the
next film if we're going off the games
and this is panama and i think that he's
been sending these postcards out to show
nate that he hasn't died someone is
clearly stopping them from getting out
though and it'll be interesting to see
if they bring hector alcazar in in order
for him to escape now sam wants to give
his brother a warning more than anything
and this likely ties in with gabriel
roman whose name gets dropped in the
second post-credits scene this moment
was actually shown in the trailers and
it was revealed that sully now has his
mustache here we meet palau asbeck's
gage who is working for roman and
similarly the villain he wears all white
in case you don't know roman is the
villain from the first game and he ended
up looking for eldorado which turned out
to be a giant gold sarcophagus inside of
it was a mummified corpse that turned
all that came into contact with it in
the flash hungry zombies the germans in
world war ii actually managed to uncover
it and this transformed the entire unit
on the island into the undead everyone
was completely unaware of this and they
thought it was just gold but it turned
out to be far more sinister the second
scene has a discussion about a map in it
that was used by the germans and it's
likely setting up the events of the
first entry now both the pair look a lot
closer to how they do in the games and
sully even gets a cigar whilst nate has
one of his classic t-shirts this moment
revolves highly around trying to buy
nate's ring which is also riffing on the
scene that opened up the third game
sully and drake escaped the bar only to
be stopped dead in their tracks and who
this could be we just don't know
potentially though it is eddie raja and
there is a gold gun that's used in the
scene so it could be hinting towards him
now that kind of takes me into the
review section of the video and though
it's getting hated on i actually quite
liked the movie i'm a big uncharted fan
and even bought a psb that just to play
golden abyss i think that they made the
best uncharted movie that they could
make for a first outing and though it
does have some issues overall it's still
a fun ride i'm someone who completely
hated the casting when it was first
announced and to be honest the trailers
didn't really do much to change my mind
when the movie first opened on the plane
scene and holland started off i cringed
a bit and just thought that they
completely dropped the ball in terms of
getting the actors right however as the
movie went on i actually thought that he
grew into the role and come the end of
it i think that both holland and
wahlberg managed to just fall into place
really well together they've got some
great back and forth and the movie does
a good job of recapturing the
exploration scenes where characters just
walk about and have conversations they
also do the spectacles really well and
the plane scene is exactly as how good
you'd expect it to be though antonio
banderas does get underused i think that
braddock is quite a good villain but i
do wish that we learned more about her
history and got flashes of her
attempting to kill sam the movie is
brought to you by the numbers and if
you've played any of the games you'll
see the plot points coming a mile off
they of course took heavily from indiana
jones and this movie even name drops him
to let you know that it's ribbing from
the iconic archaeologist too perhaps
that's why they avoided bringing in the
nazis in this one as it would lead to
more comparisons but out of all the
indie clones i think this one ranks near
at the top i actually prefer it way over
tomb raider and though it doesn't get
everything right it does get enough what
i'm saying is is that the movie is fine
it's not gonna break the internet but
it's also not bad and it handles
everything it tries to do quite well as
a fan of the game i think they adapted
the source material really well and it
didn't drop the ball on any of the
action overall uncharted was a great
ride and it gets a 7 out of 10. now i'd
of course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we're running competition right now
and giving away three copies of june on
the 28th of feb and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now say that to
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the book of bob affair
which will be linked on screen right now
go over there i've told you what you're
still doing here get the hell out of
here you goddamn punk just still here on
you
go bye